[Music]
somebody else so um this is um
brendan schaub
yay
was
uh on
[Music]
was on a show with bro if i if if we got
a sponsorship right
even if they did pay us a lot of money
right
if they sent us that sign that powered
by rain sign
i'd be like
i didn't agree to have a sign the size
of the goddamn studio i think like what
is this [ __ ] murray's arcade like
[ __ ] you know what i mean like i'll
give you a sponsored by such and such
but like
we're not changing the whole goddamn try
putting up a sign the size of the wall
so
okay so first off
um then i'm going to have to return the
revenge of the sauce neon lights i got
for the studio yeah yeah you better you
guys are doing it no
no damn it you keep
we'll we'll talk about it
all right hold on hold on we'll talk
about it all right all right let's say
let's say
you've entered a hellscape alternate
dimension
where you have to do revenge of the
sauce
i'll kill myself
what i okay
all right well you pick a flavor before
you [ __ ] eat the bullet what's the
flavor
i don't i'm not hungry
what about a malt liquor called revenge
of the schlitz
[Music]
to answer your question virgie garlic
parmesan bullet please
garlic parmesan 45 yeah spicy honey
barbecue there you go
um anyway start the clip here today
spicy honey barbecued and zyklon so
anyway um
brendan shaw burke kreischer were on
some sort of show you'll be funny as you
get like rained sorry i just stopped on
this brand now
you get rain to sponsor your show and
then we just we just keep dumping ghosts
into rain cans off the air
so we're like
i love race so good i love rain energy
so burke ricer and brandon schaub are on
some show and they're talking about the
you know our craft
ari shafir dope you know the soldiers
versus the civilians the civilians yes
the the war on combat fighting in the
trenches
the uh
[ __ ] stop referring to the comedy
store is that please
um as the trenches
the [ __ ] any place that has kid rocks
picture in black and white on it
that's all
um any place that's gonna have stevo on
wednesday and thursday isn't to be that
wild any place that has mick foley
telling a story on stage is fine so
anyway burke kreischer
brendan schaub
are talking about the ari shafir
incident why shafir
dosed them with was it acid acid right
yeah people like where you also got to
go in person like when when ari drugged
me i couldn't just [ __ ] talk about
that in therapy yeah because all of a
sudden someone's still why are you going
to therapy
because they're they're all profoundly
broken sad people yeah so i thought and
that is the biggest podcast that bert
christ were talking for an hour with a
dude who's listening about what it felt
like to be drugged by a by his best
friend and and and so like there's a lot
of things i just i couldn't share in
therapy because i was i only are your
best friend no
but you don't like his ska outfit
what's he doing
well he's about to break out his [ __ ]
harmonica he's dressed like he's in a
boy band from like the
2000s like when the boy band trends
started dying out but they were still
making them yeah he's the stupid one
he's one of those late boy band guys
yeah seriously
no no no oh no are you oh no or he's not
my best friend but tommy's my best
friend but he's already one of my
closest friends if it's my space
wait can i can i point something out
here
this meant these are grown men right can
you imagine
the four of us we're all friends
and you imagine you are yeah can you
imagine if like we're talking about
something and and you know something
happens and merc did something let's see
merch [ __ ] put drugs in my in my
energy drink and then and then and then
pessy were to go to they would waste
drugs like i know but then pes you'd be
like man how does it feel that your your
best friend drug you like that
i would it would i wouldn't make a big
deal out of it i would just be like yeah
it's [ __ ] horrible he's my friend or
whatever i wouldn't get stuck on he's
not actually my best friend he's my good
friend my third best friend because i
have my best friend my best best friend
and then my my one of my besties from
he's like an f not a bff this is like
explaining to the other guy why he's not
going to be your best man i don't
understand this
who cares
that is a high school that little
childish back and forth is the exact
problem with all these la comics that
mentality of like he's a good friend but
he's not a best friend what are you
gonna write that in your diary
dude they're all perma children
jesus christ
they're just they're stuck in their
[ __ ] childhood
they're because i was i because i only
are
this is la right so you know they're
like oh okay see
you're you're you're a great wife you're
not my the best wife i've had yeah but
you're like you're like my second
favorite wife
no no no oh no are you oh no or he's not
my best friend but tommy's my best
friend but or he's already one of my
closest friends what does that mean
wait
wait wait what person in their 40s even
in their 30s
is i'm not going to give you the title
of best friend
are there any people that are really on
i'm not honest i'm joking aside are
there any people that are actually
really like this yes
in l.a
i i i i don't know all of them this is
why esther what's her face eats xanax
all day and just zones out while
everyone's talking
it's my space already's in your top
eight oh yeah
oh my god they did the thing no you
should do this
you should you should try the myspace
line again
you think you'll do a third you'll think
you'll say myspace a third time i'd say
remember with like the top friends of
mike space i bet you just one more time
i know that ari is for a lot of people
listening
i understand jewish and what people
think about ari i think he's jewish but
like my assistant i happen to agree with
royce
royce has a good take on that you know
who agrees with us ari mark norman's
bachelor party is a great comic but my
assistant
thank you thank you for that
contribution
or he could make me laugh
in the middle of him talking like he
always does in the middle of him saying
a sentence
it's just he's a good comic he just
blurts things
out he's a good comic i hate him even
joking it's annoying right you know we
we do it to each other when we watch
brendan clips and it's like
[ __ ] so bad
and said
to me
the last day he's like we're having a
beer at the airport and their flight
gets delayed mark
joe derosa and ari's flight gets laid
and they come over and my assistant goes
my assistant's a solid [ __ ] dude top
to bottom and he goes i met him a male
assistant that's weird he goes
i wanted to hate him
i said what he was like one grown man
[ __ ] just openly talking about their
therapy sessions oh yeah yeah this is an
r this is and then and then there'll
still be people in the comments that'll
be like [ __ ] jealous what's wrong it's
because he's funnier than you look
fine funnier than me fine find all those
things you could put all those things on
me but at the end of the day do these
people seem happy to you
do these people seem like they're lit
that they're happy they get
progressively more miserable the more
therapy they go to yeah it's therapy
makes people worse you know it's because
they don't get go to therapists because
they need therapists they go to
therapists because they showed off their
therapist [ __ ] their therapist car
business card like they show off their
[ __ ] cars and [ __ ] it's a commodity
to them someone's got to get them pills
too
he's the sweetest guy in the world he is
there's a part of ari that is
that is people don't see it he you know
arya say whatever he's still talking
every once about me but i doubt i don't
understand the two of you i don't
understand
that's right ari has talked [ __ ] on
brandon's shop a few times
oh i i kind of do really why i have no
i've no it will be brandon it's because
you're not [ __ ] funny and you keep
being handed things that normally
[ __ ] people that are funny have to
work their [ __ ] ass off to get you
piece of [ __ ] it hurt he looked so hurt
there yeah it that that killed him
you i don't understand oh i kind of do
really why i have no i have no ill will
towards them i know at all me me and i
have done shows together um
but ari uh say something gets taken out
of context and i don't have his number
usually
what's it out of context we've heard
what he said about you in context it was
very funny and he was making fun of you
not boys at all jesus christ it looks
like he should be singing happy with
pharrell like what's he doing like it's
not it's
fashion choice oh my god he does he
looks like he's going to a halloween
party as pharrell yeah exactly
he looks like he's going to be in robin
thicke's new video
he'll text me like hey man legit he'll
be like that pico de gallo
pico de gallo
he'll be like this came out the one
thing i don't do is [ __ ] on other
comments i saw that i saw that that was
[ __ ] [ __ ] but it's not real but
but but also yeah no it's not real it's
not real and it's well that's not that's
what was [ __ ] about it i was like
why are you you little you you little
therapy little sissies
always defending this guy i don't
understand it ari is one of the few
dudes who is funnier than both of these
guys all of them really in my opinion
ari's one of the funniest dudes probably
around
and
you know what chrysler wanted to say
there with the ari thing
i'll re i could read his mind because
typical therapy stuff this is what he
said when he was like when he was like
oh i don't know why you have a problem
with you well actually i do what he
actually wanted to say is maybe he goes
into it i don't know but what he
actually wanted to say is because he's
jealous of you man it's because he's
been he's been at it longer than you and
you're but guaranteed and told me that's
what he'll say off the air yeah
you know i don't care you know i have no
ill will towards arya at all i like him
he did a set in indianapolis a handful
years ago and we went down to meet him
or went down to the show and we just
happened to be recognized in the front
um and dude he was [ __ ] doped us we
went out went drinking afterwards
and he was he was really cool and how
would you know he's a good time you just
even said you don't even have his phone
number
respectful to everybody i was around
we've just done we have all the same
mutual friends that's the podcast i want
to see just you and him
hey hey brendan does that tell you
something yeah if i have all this
unaware brendan is unaware and we never
hang out then probably
maybe you figure out you're the problem
the you and him i would love to see that
podcast because
i wouldn't do i know you would no hold
on yes i would i take that back i keep
thinking about content for us yes please
do it
and i know him and i i think i surround
me like the people that hate me are
textbook uh sociopaths like
everyone that hates me is a sociopath
wait a second
does this guy
burp christ your things
and by the way i'm not one of those
dudes that like hates we don't really
talk about pressure that much so this
isn't me going into it like i have like
some deep seated i don't
but
burke christchurch just said
that everybody that hates him it's
because they're sociopaths which again
what's the what kind of therapy are you
going to when a therapist is not telling
you you need to take blame for some of
the things in your life well everyone
that dislikes me is a sociopath yeah i i
don't think that's true
bert i'm gonna turn every single person
into the chat of sociopath and then
you're like okay fine here you go i
guess [ __ ] usually zoloft
how about sometimes you do things that
are stupid how about we're all sick of
you making the machine your entire
[ __ ] personality
i mean i just i know who hates me like
i'm not saying look if you're listening
this you're like i'm not a fan of birds
there's an issue i have that i need to
clean why was that cut correct and i'm
i'm projecting on bert yeah like you you
need to see birds therapy and i and you
need to see birds and why would i want
to see bert's therapist it's doing
horrors for him why would i want to use
the same thing look bro i don't want to
ever be like the guy so why would i want
him
i'm not going to
go to a therapist of a guy that i would
kill myself if i was them yeah i don't
understand that and i and and and ours
links just in case you want to you know
maybe see if everybody in chat's a
sociopath oh i remember this remember
the at the burke chrysler adam sandler
thing that we played during the pandemic
like two years ago
when that when you as soon as you see
the first frame you're going to remember
ladies and gentlemen this next comedian
yes yes yes this
charity
is
uh
burke kreischer embarrasses himself in
front of adam sandler we played this on
the show april 5th 2020. i'm not playing
oh i remember this but it's no no no no
no all no is one of my comedic heroes he
is the reason i do stand up he is the
reason i've been writing movies that
have never been made but i love his
movies i love everything about this guy
without further ado
the guy that defined all our
personalities adam sandler oh my god
that was
unbelievable thank you
thank you
adam have you ever heard of bert he
doesn't think you know who he is i i've
seen bert right
he's trying to be nice man
dude it quickly goes from like adam
sandler's trying to like oh that was
something and by the end of it he's just
like all right man i just wanna i just
wanna go i just wanna i don't wanna be
here
skip to the other video boys just oh i
know oh i know here and just not know
like just towards just towards the end
somewhere where you
oh god would they just rip on them
oh there was so much going there bert
kreischer
humiliated himself in front of adam
he said everything wrong you could
possibly say to adam
short of asking why do your movies suck
now
oh my god man
i i do love big j man
big jay will [ __ ]
he will always go for the joke oh yeah
unlike therapists i think guys
like i said
uh my my daughters hate him my daughters
hate him and my wife hates him he'll
never come and never come he'll never oh
that's right why are they sociopaths
anyone that doesn't like ari shafir is
probably a sociopath flip it around is
i would play this clip and go yeah i
guess crisis kids and his wife were
anti-semitic that's all i would do that
would be a [ __ ] funny angle yeah
everyone's on the show every time you
see christ you're on the show you're
like yeah cause your wife and your kids
that [ __ ] hate jews
i will never come to my house what was
they dropping to you molly that's right
oh i'm sorry that they had had you have
a good time yeah so i can't readable it
was on my podcast yeah and everyone's
like release it and that's this is what
sucks about the internet but you go
you don't i i know better what you want
to see than you you're not going to want
it's not just it's going to hurt it's
not what you think it's also going to
hurt more it's not i watched it and man
when you see in my eyes
when you realize what happened so you
started feeling some kind of way and
you're like man i feel [ __ ] weird
hold on pause pause pause pause pause
ari shafir dropped [ __ ] molly in his
drink and it's on camera
and all of his fans begged him to
release it and this [ __ ] just
said
i know what you want to watch better
than you do and he won't release it but
instead he will talk about it yeah but
through my eyes the really embarrassing
thing that i did while i was on molly
it's just it's not something that yeah
but it's that arrogance but here's the
thing you have to understand it's that
arrogance bert does this a lot because
he got caught he's got caught doing it
before and the other comics get caught
doing this a lot and a lot of people you
just hate him because you're jealous
that's not true if you watch the show we
rarely ever go new york comics it's very
rare that we're like oh look how cringe
because they're [ __ ] they hating
themselves
but instead of going to therapists they
do drugs so it's just more fun i just
dude i wouldn't care about the therapist
or any of that [ __ ] i just hate anybody
who go who [ __ ] makes their entire
personality i'm funny
and they're not no but but but even if
he was funny even if he's the funniest
person that's ever lived even if this is
the funniest guy there ever was
the problem the problem with that is
that is you know why he'll never be the
funniest guy there ever was because he
talks like he is an expert at comedy and
i really that line is very telling it's
like like you said virgin you said murph
we all said it it caught everyone off
guard with the
i know what's funny you don't well to be
fair he's right because they are
civilians but and it's like that
mentality that's why
starbucks was so much was so funny when
he called everybody out he's like look
man i respect the average doc worker
more than any comic like
and that's the mentality they really
think i know what's funny more than you
dude that's why staff can walk out and
do
[ __ ] 20 minutes of crowd work
just i make on par if not better jokes
yeah well he can go out and do just 20
minutes of [ __ ] crowd work straight
burke chrysler goes out and immediately
takes his [ __ ] shirt off that's a
really good point he hasn't written on
his [ __ ] he actually hasn't written
down on his show notes
it's like
shirt oh it's like
airplane food
you know it's like uh local local city
jokes
shirt off and then after that machine
i think it's literally just a piece of
paper that just says shirt off and
machine that's it
and it's written in bacon grease
the fact that he hasn't released it is
kind of weird to me like just i would
have by now right yeah cool it's [ __ ]
weird and
then he said by the way if if you watch
it i'm doing it just we can't watch it
yes
but he's like do you do you
if you watch it
he's high on molly and he's saying it
high on molly and he's like do you do
you and i was like i was like yeah why
and he's like
he's like maybe
you you can't be mad and i was like what
he's like maybe i put something in your
drink
when i realized that moment i realized i
chugged it
i downed it and i demanded more drugs
you know what my answer would have been
to ari
it would have been you put some
oh yeah
here's what mine would have been mine
would have been like well
here we go i would have got right you
could go with it i mean i would i mean i
would still be pissed i would be i would
be pissed but what would you release it
i would be would you release the video
yeah make a couple bucks off
exactly this is how [ __ ] good at
that drugs i am
that's not the time to be angry that's a
good angry afterwards but like let's get
all [ __ ] let's get all pissy and [ __ ]
at least you're right like a point be
angry later don't waste them all it's
true
it's not cool it's like it's like the
same thing about like no i'm way closer
with you than right not even close way
closer we know we know you have so many
friends and everybody loves
sneakers and you're nice
he just did he need to say that he's
closer to him no after he did a [ __ ]
15-minute introduction about how [ __ ]
orientated nobody is saying that that's
not is he even listening nobody is
saying that no is he listening
dude
i love you yeah i don't love her i don't
know
i don't love you i don't know it's like
myspace
when i heard that that pistol so once
you reach your friend what the [ __ ] are
you doing i'm just trying to hash it up
but
so once you once you recognize it your
response was he has to get on a flight
too and he's around his kids it's pretty
fairly complicated because why are you
talking for him yeah
all right cool i just wanted to make
sure yeah just tell me to refresh we're
back sorry about that guys start with a
little fart we should be back
get it because uh yeah cosby
because
one of those dudes yeah
brendan just like looks in your eyes
and you can tell he's not listening he's
just thinking of the next thing he wants
to say oh yeah i want you to go back a
couple seconds i need you to hear from
the the plane him saying she had to fly
watch how many times he does this
no yeah when i heard that that pistol so
once you reach your friend what the [ __ ]
are you doing i'm just trying to hash it
but i don't know so once you once you
recognize it your response was he has to
get on a flight too and he's around his
kids it's pretty fairly complicated
because uh he had cosby but he won't
stop he got cosby
well no because that that would imply
that ari shafir then raped him well
did ari shafir rape you bird is that why
you're not releasing the tape and did
you maybe like it
and if he did rape you on your podcast
really you should release it you don't
know [ __ ] if you don't think people
don't want to see when you were on molly
was he taking you from behind and you
were telling him to call you call me the
machine call me the machine
okay
so i know there's some talented
[ __ ] in chat yeah we really
need bert chrysler's face over ned
beatty's and [ __ ] deliverance i like
that here
and then
just on one of the trees in the
background hang his stupid [ __ ] neon
sign
because i also look i wouldn't like to
be dosed i will agree with that and that
would make me pissed i would also be
pissed but they're trying to make it
sound like he's never going to be able
to see his kids and family again or go
on a flight you could be on a flight on
molly you'll be fine yeah okay stop it
it's not like he dosed you with lsd
while you were like driving a car or
flying a plane you'll be all right you
you know what you do you have the best
flight you've ever had in your life it's
what you have and you keep going ding
can i have more water yeah just more
water please is it hot you just have the
thing a full blast
you're asking other people to turn their
little air things on too
and you just you just keep rubbing your
seatbelt for no reason
you know what's up
i'm on molly um i'm having a panic
attack i have to be on a flight it's not
my it's in my house in his house around
his kids and my kids and wife are there
but bums me out so much is
ari was like uh
i don't know i don't want to get too
deep into it but like he released a
video okay he was he was very friendly
be more upset that you just that you
brought drugs in my house with my
[ __ ] kids yeah you know what are you
putting like drugs in my [ __ ] like if
this was just at his studio that's a
good point that's a good point that does
kind of change things up a little bit
too right
yeah oh yeah absolutely about getting
drugs like he's that's an afterthought
to him like me like that would be my
main contention after the fact like
you're in for the ride you might as well
just [ __ ] let it ride
in our house yeah i'm not saying i would
fight you about it immediately i'm just
saying i would be pissed and i'd be like
all right oh no you should be too he
showed up he was always traveling he
always had a backpack he was always
doing laundry you know and and like him
and isla connected and they they found
him funny and it was fun and then you
know in one stupid thing he did he made
it so that now my daughters hate his
guys understandably understandably and
my wife hates his guts and and i had a
month i had a month where i you know
like like i call whitney cummings and
the next day at half so let's say all of
this is true
but i and and i think from his
perspective it is true and he he has
given a lot of points that
i will agree with him on like you know
bringing drugs in the house and there's
kids there and getting dosed i would be
pissed and i'm being realistic whether i
think christ responding not how funny
ari is that is true but here's the part
that i don't understand and this is what
tiger belly does and this is what they
do
why do you keep bringing it up on air
like this is some personal [ __ ] that you
hash out why would you get even though
your p you say your wife and your
daughter are mad
why would you bring them into this on an
episode of a show like that to me is the
part where it's a unique uniquely la
comic thing to do
where they but then at the same time
he'll tell you everything that happened
on this show and how bad it was but then
also he won't release you don't want to
see that though because you know why i
think he probably i mean i haven't seen
it so here's the problem we have to
guess i think he probably had a good
time
i think he probably maybe got a little
pissed at first but he probably read and
he had a good time and they were joking
and they were laughing yeah and then he
probably doesn't want to like you know
he's been milking it as a victim for so
many years now he doesn't want people to
go back and go you look like you're
probably fine
yeah it would have been like like maybe
also i know this is silly but it's a
question that i think is fair to ask how
much molly
i i'm not saying it's right or wrong it
doesn't make it right it doesn't make it
right but the amount does matter a lot
think that's probably a lot
dude i guarantee you guarantee you yeah
i think it might be
like a point in his [ __ ] in his dream
yeah i think it might be the opposite
yeah maybe probably just micro dosed him
a little bit yeah i mean again i don't
know you know
i mean a point or two with some good
molly will get you feeling good it's not
gonna make you [ __ ] yes you're not
gonna get lit